A recent Knit it Now Machine-Knitable
was this beautiful wrap that was knit
diagonally. Using self-striping yarn
the designer started at a point
knit to the width of the wrap and then
continued knitting diagonally.
She added a mixture of Garter stitch
sections with some open work sections,
and this added texture
and interest to the wrap.
The construction is pretty simple.
It looks like this. Cast on three stitches.
Increase one stitch at the beginning
of every row until the piece
is as wide as you like.
Then decrease on one side and increase
on the opposite side,
forming that diagonal shaping.
To finish, decrease one stitch
at the beginning of every row until there
are three stitches in work and bind off.
As machine knitters,
we can easily use this technique and her
design as inspiration for our knitting.
But there are some things to consider.
Most often, hand-knit diagonals
are knit with Garter stitch.
By its nature, the gauge of Garter
stitch is more square than Stockinette.
Compare these samples and you'll see
that the point of my hand knit diagonal
swatch is more of a square shape.
Where the point of my stockinette
machine-knit sample is
somewhat distorted by comparison.
Just something to consider.
Another thing is the fact
that stockinette curls.
There are a number of ways to reduce
the curl, and for this inspiration piece,
machine knitters could alternate some rows
of reverse Stockinette,
alternating the knit and purl sides.
We could manually add some Garter ridges
or add stripes of another stitch pattern
to add texture and interest
to the project.
Just like the original.
How many rows to knit?
Hand knitters can measure their
knitting accurately as they go
as we knit on our machines.
We're stretching that knitting across
the needle bed and hanging weights.
We can't measure accurately
with the knitting hanging on the machine.
So how do we know how many rows to knit?
Normally,
swatching gives us that information.
But for a shape like this,
calculating the hypotenuse and the legs
and the number of rows involves math
that is well beyond my capabilities.
With your swatch, you already know your
row gauge and you should be able
to estimate how many rows are needed.
Keep in mind that scarves and shawls
don't need to be an exact length.
The last consideration is the construction
of the knitting on a knitting machine.
In the center section of this design,
we increase along one edge
and decrease along the opposite side.
Shaping in this matter moves your knitting
across the needle bed. So there needs
to be enough room for this movement.
As you knit your scarf or shawl,
you may need to remove the work
from the machine with a Garter bar, hand
knitting needle, or just scrap off.
Move the knitting to the other end
of the bed and rehang the stitches.
And then you can continue the shaping.
With this in mind,
knitting a blanket with this technique
means knitting the blanket in pieces.
You have to have enough empty
needles to work the center
increase/decrease section.
You could create a very interesting
blanket design with self-striping yarn or
different colors. And alternate
the direction of the strips.
You could even turn one strip
with the purl side showing the other
with the knit side showing
for a reversible blanket.
I'm sure this basic technique of knitting
diagonally will inspire projects
in your knitting future.